are you concerned with critical races  absolutely it's gotta go  not for young  it could be taught hot no yeah it is  being taught in some some schools some  schools are fighting it so it's not  there yet but i can guarantee you around  the united states  at a very young age and it's very sad  very sad  it will change this whole country what  is critical risk what is critical race  theory critical race there is a lot of  things i've not done a lot of research  on it but there's a lot of things in it  the uh total race-baiting  uh teachings the uh helping out with the  uh lgbtq i can't even say because i'm  just letting that that they don't work  yeah they're teaching sex education to  the kids i mean there's just all kinds  of stuff  with it i'm not good on that because i  can't like give it but yeah